foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn about vlookup function in
Excel but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon never miss an update from
Simply love now without further Ado
let's get started with vlookup in Excel
so what exactly is vlookup function
basically vlookup function is a lookup
method involving to fetch the data from
a tabular data set Now vlookup function
is a pre-made function in Excel which
allows searches across columns so
basically we have three type of lookup
functions and vlookup as one of those we
have vlookup hlookup and X lookup
vlookup is vertical lookup Edge lookup
is horizontal lookup and X is a
combination of both V and H lookup so
the syntax for vlookup is as follows so
we will have a lookup value that is the
cell address or the value which you are
looking for and the table array which is
the range of elements that you want to
look out for and the column is the
resultant column from which you want the
result and the match is it supposed to
be an exact match or the nearest match
so I believe the theoretical explanation
of the syntax is incomplete with without
having a practical demonstration so
let's get back to Excel and try to
execute some vlookup functions so that
you have a quickly a lookup function and
especially a vlookup function Works in
Excel right we are on the Excel
spreadsheet right now so let's start
with our simple one right so here I will
have car and price so here I will give
up a drop down menu using data
validation so that you can simply choose
the data right so we will go to data
data validation
test and the source will be
these are the marks for the source and
press OK you don't have to enter any
error messages Etc so no error messages
and more details on data validation in
Excel please go through the data
validation Excel tutorial by simple now
and now in the price section we will
have the vlookup function right now the
first one lookup value which is this
particular cell right so we look up
function will look for the value here so
let's say I give Lamborghini and then it
will fetch the cost of Lamborghini from
the table so where is it looking for the
value first lookup value as Lamborghini
which is right in front of car in the
cell A5 so that is the first parameter
we need to provide or attribute we need
to send out then the table array which
table array should it look for this is
the table array it looks more and I'm
eliminating the header over here you
need to automate the header and the
column index number right now we are
giving car name and now we want the
price so in the table car s column 1
price as column 2 right even if this
particular car price is around anywhere
in the table car is still considered as
column one price is still considered as
calling two so we need the value from
column two right so we will provide a
column number two and the last one exact
match we want the exact match not
appropriate match so select that press
on tap to select now close the value
right close the bracket now let's get
back to cover and now select any one of
the cards let's select BMW right now
when you select BMW what lookup is doing
is it is first checking the value here
look up value is BMW so since we got the
value spmw it will go back to this
particular table and fetch for the name
BMW right and now it has the BMW data
and now the third parameter that is
column to right so it will check column
2 and see the exact match what is the
value of the car 75 or 750 uh million
right 7.5 million dollars so that will
give you the data over here
so that's how vlookup works now this is
still a fundamental understanding of new
lookup let's elaborate a little more to
understand it in a much better way right
now I I have here the slide data right
and here you can see when I select the
source
and destination
and flight
which I want to fly in then it's it's
giving me the price of the flight and
the route in which it is going how did I
do it so let's do it practically right
so we will get back here
and
here we will do some changes
okay it's okay
now here we have everything
the
source and destination
airline price on route
let's also provide
Source will be again data validation
go to data
data validation
will be a list
this is the list press ok
and destination is again data validation
select list
and now the list of destinations
and the airline
is again a data validation operation
where you will give the set of
or the list of airlines which you are
offering
and okay
now comes the price
equals to vlookup
passing these three values
and table array
which is again the same
the entire table except
the headers
next will be the column number so one
two three four and five prices in the
fifth column so I will pass column
number five and I want exact match not
appropriate match press tab to select
close-up bracket and enter
right and the same applies to the route
so equals to or you can just copy the
formula and paste it here
and make a minor change that is instead
of column number five you want column
number four which has the router data
right so column number four has the
route data enter and there you go now
out of the drop down when you select
source as any uh location here let's
select Mumbai and the destination as
Bangalore and Airline as let's fly in
Air India and you have the price details
and filler so these particular ones you
can
you know hide because the data is coming
over here so you can copy paste it to
this place
and let's hide these things
and you can also hide this one as well
there you go now the data is visually a
little more appealing and you can kind
of have a complete you know dashboard
where you have the data of vlookup
results
right so whenever you select any
source and give any destination
from the drop down and choose any of the
flights you want to fly with
and you will have the data over here
write the price of the applied and the
root of the flight and that's how you
use vlookup in Excel so if you want to
learn more of such interesting skills
and techniques to become successful
business analyst through an online
training and certification program then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in business
analysis from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be the right choice
please click on the link in the
description box below so that you can
get a complete overview of the program
being offered and before we end this
tutorial on vlookup now before we
conclude let's listen from our Learners
about their success story after getting
certified by simply launch postgraduate
program in business analysis from Toyota
University I have always been passionate
about learning new things and improving
my teaching skills about five years ago
I realized that I have a gap in my
knowledge and to fill the Gap I needed
work skill myself I chose simply
learning at my upskilling partner
because of all its comprehensive
curriculum and its connection with Urdu
University
hi my name is Carlos vinares I live in
Lexington in the city of Kentucky in the
United States I am an assistant
professor at Midway University and I
hold a PhD in management human resources
and Leadership I decided to opt for the
post graduation program in business
analysis from cellular which has helped
me a lot in my professional and personal
life I have been teaching even before I
moved to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business I'm telling
students
it was very difficult for me at the
beginning
but after completing this class and
learning how to use tools like Excel
Tableau power bi power query problem I
feel like it has been a total game
changer for me now I apply these skills
everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
YouTube reviews I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis
starting in Fall 2023
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot and
finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
you see how the business works is
changing now when you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the exchange everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing and with that we have
come to an end of this session on
vlookup in Excel if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you want the
resources that we used in this session
then please do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign